Well
[Music]
how are you, Hector Mejía greets you with his
brief informative today is Thursday
September 16 life is virus begins tomorrow
and downtown Las Vegas is ready
to hold this event which
attracts more than 170 thousand people among
artists  highlights for friday
are making the bees they also have
for the class we have this festival
will have additional health protection measures in
addition to checking your
vaccination status or a
negative kobe test to enter
if you want to get the
coronavirus vaccine there are several options
around the valley this week there will be
one today tomorrow at the gas stations
from 6 pm to 7:30 pm
all fans who decide to get vaccinated on
this site
will receive a free ticket to the
mexico game on facebook party another
clinic will happen tomorrow  in older carme
and presentation from 4 in the
afternoon until 7 at night
there are too many events around the
valley celebrate  hen the day of
independence of mexico to begin two
baseball teams from mexico will
perform tonight in las vegas for
park the fashion show will have
mariachi bands and folkloric dances all
week alejandro fernández will perform
at the embryo urbina tonight the
artist  mexican always travels to
las vegas' during national holidays and
take advantage because restaurants
are also offering discounts
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have some breezes for today we
will stay below 100
degrees there is a slight chance of
rain for tomorrow and saturday  the
temperatures will drop little by little this
week for the next we could see
some days with maximum temperatures in
the 80s have a nice day electro mejía greets you
and this was your brief
informative of innings in spanish